[Applaudissements]
j'ai tout perdu mon sang froid et sa
carte non c'est ce qui s'est passé
peut-être ta baisser mon chéri attend
regard et l'ardenne kutxa vue d'alléger
sa tu veux pas tu as côté montceau
prendrais toi comme ça je triche pas
encore la peur de jean michel maire on
m'a dit du même après venu faire
attention à toi côté soarano soprano ça
cartonne pour lui ça cartonne vraiment
cosmopolitan s'est sorti le 13 octobre
et c'est vrai que c'est un carton
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dix ans d'albums solo tu as commencé
j'avais 12 ans coiffé les bricoles pas
j'avais 15 ans et white ra et mon avec
mon groupe les psy4 de la rime
alonso avait 12 ans je sais qu'il
cartonne aussi on l'était légaux
ville-etat binta wenta roddick l'avait
laissé ça c'est la non merci
est ce que tu me quittes je chante je
suis en feu façon matthieu delormeau
quoi tu m'as tout essayé
[Applaudissements]
premier arrêté
connect je connais que la première
phrase mais cela fait plutôt bien la
danse de la commune eddine zidane face à
l'équipe du brésil suis un peu ce soir
j'ai par la suite ce soir j'aimerais
ramener des glaçons ya aussi d'autres
trucs je vais juste tester un truc jeudi
jeffrey aller encore plus loin
si je fais on voit le match et cyril ont
fait à la bien pour les mecs comme
adblock on le fait à la bien aimée qui
sont épais on le fait à la famille 50 10
sopra doc est avec nous l'album sort
demain est vraiment moche reproche pas
ça parce que nous serons de ses fans de
toit et un et nature franchement yamilé
pas excellent il est au top et au top
c'est ceara sens et un carton et c'est
un phénomène
vous voulez coupé jeu coupal et j'ai
coupé parce que comme ça où vous allez
voir qu'il n'ya pas de triche a pas de
triche attention c'est parti on va
démarrer un futur mais j'ai l'impression
que ça triste très bon j'ai bonne
mémoire sont chers attention vous voulez
démarrer vous voulez prendre la première
carte nous apprend ainsi commence
allez je commence attention il n'y a pas
une petite musique d'ambiance dame de
coeur
j'ai pas mal je suis pas mal pour des
serviettes et savez on a une telle
petite production
allez-y soprano devra se battre ici on
est débouté dépouille déboutonnée oh
merde
heureusement direct déjà ah bah oui bah
oui c'est ça à tanger nord celle là ça
va peut-être voir fait de voir ça yaya
et l'os est de piques à la la la la moue
sopra non mon cher prévient le joueur
médecin hiver c'est rien du tout y aura
[Applaudissements]
versé top tibet reste vous voulez
démarrer sur la prochaine manche démarre
c'est moi qui dès mardi l'accord alesi
et vous allez voir est directe attention
des marées vertes avoir des seins je
crains que le rsa va là je sais après je
sais je connais après ça fait comme une
petite raie à l'artificiel ces
problématiques sa stature bus ou bon au
moins tout le monde sait que c'est pas
moi qui ai l avez vous inquiétez pas
c'est comme alesi sopra soprano le cet
accord le 7 7 de coeur je peux faire moi
j'ai quand même prendre le verbe le roi
y'a pas de ces boîtes à savon me
réchauffer je fais quelques points
adacore allez-y c'est vous alors ça y
est il est chaud attention attention
non c'est pas moi aussi moi aussi je
vais perdre à un moment
[Applaudissements]
oui
sopra moi je comprends pas parce qu'on
joue il faut pas salir mon nom joue à
nancy
[Musique]